And for me the problem is that this solution uses too much memory, uses it unnecessarily.
We quit this gigantic list with a million elements and actually a million and one elements
and we don't ever use it again.
We just use it once to calculate the sum. That seems like sort of waste to me.
And this is exactly the motivation for generator expression.
We don't want to create list that we're never going to use.
So if we want to solve this exact same problem with the generator expression,
it's a simple as converting brackets to parenthesis.
Actually, we could do away with one set of parenthesis here but I'm going to leave them in
and running gives the exact same result.
Interesting aside here since range is actually creating a gigantic list as well,
we can use Python's built-in xrange function--
basically, this prevents us from generating this entire list.
Okay. So now we know how to use generator expressions.
Let's poke around a bit and figure out exactly what's going on inside of them.